good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have a special ability to create
something amazing that can change the
planet so to help you on your journey
today we're going to talk about how to
deal with difficult people
[Music]
your ability to deal with people is
going to have more of an influence on
your success and Happiness than any
other skill you can develop now it's
easy to deal with pleasant positive
cheerful people it's when you have to
deal with difficult people that you
really demonstrate the quality of your
personality and your ability to function
well in a competitive society so how do
you deal with difficult people people
who have problems people who are angry
people who are frustrated people who
attack you
worst of all people who do not mean you
any good and want to take advantage of
you
keep your perspective as being a
champion of humanity what I mean by that
you know what happens often times when
we're frustrated with other people is
we've lost our connection with humanity
in some way or another we're in a big
hurry and we forgotten that people have
stories and realities that we do not
know about you don't know what is going
on in somebody's day when they just
pissed you off right they just did
something and you think oh well you know
they're like this or they were going
like this you don't know maybe you had a
co-worker who was supposed to deliver
something in the morning and they didn't
deliver now you're fired up and you're
frustrated about them but you didn't
know that
oh the their child woke up in the
morning he was throwing up a whole
morning and and they haven't slept in
the last nine hours sometimes you don't
know that somebody had a death in the
family
sometimes you don't know somebody on
their way to work got some terrible news
sometimes you don't know the real
challenge and frustrations people are
dealing with at their home at their in
their regular life with their family you
don't know you don't know if this person
who you're so angry with you'd feel like
guy I just wish I could punch them in
the face I'm so mad at them you don't
know that they're a victim of a domestic
violence at a home see we make all these
assumptions about people well they're
just so stupid or there's something
wrong with them and we never know their
real story and soon as you lose your
patience with people you lose your
connection with humanity you lose that
understanding that you know what stuff
happens in people's lives and maybe
right now they've had a lot of chaos and
your life is going along smooth or maybe
you're having a lot of chaos and all of
a sudden your chaos and your smoothness
or whatever it interacts and if you feel
like it's gonna explode in this great
amount of frustration and you forget
well oh gosh people have things going on
as busy as stress-filled
as you are other people have that too as
freaked out as a heavy plate of
responsibilities that you have other
people have that too and if you don't
believe that then you've gotten to a
place where you've allowed your
intellect to grow your ego to such a
level that you can't connect with
humanity anymore and I know that sounds
flippant to say but what happens for so
many people
is they do there especially folks who
are quote unquote intellectuals right
people who feel like they're very
evolved enlightened supremely conscious
what ends up happening for them is
sometimes they have lost that real
connection with humanity because they
think they're so special versus other
people and here's the ultimately the
challenge with folks who do have an ego
like that or who do feel so much more
supremely special than other people that
other people they just don't understand
how much the frustrating meet they
become very caged in their life it's
like watching an animal that is caged
that gets resigned because it's been
wild and free at some point and now it's
resigned in the back of the cage curled
up angry and frustrated pointing at
people they don't understand me they
don't understand me they don't
understand me and the folks who often
say other people don't understand me are
the same people who rarely ever raise
their hand and ask for help they're the
folks who easily get frustrated annoyed
or resign from other people and now when
they need help or when they want to
progress their life because they've
drawn away from people who they believe
to be stupid because they've drawn away
from others who they believe other
people can't understand them because
they believe other people can't
understand them they don't ask for help
they don't collaborate they don't
socialize they don't create the very
influenced relationships and networks
that is necessary for them to grow to
the next level in their life and in
their business so you have to think
about that for a moment have you got so
disconnected from other people that
you're often frustrated with them
because you forgot you don't understand
their story you don't know what they're
going through just like you're
frustrated you're and you're saying well
they don't know what I'm going through
everybody else feels that way once you
understand that really the the reality
of humanity is it's a bunch of human
beings walking around with a sign at the
top of their head that says please
understand me please be patient with me
please help then you stop getting so
frustrated with people and you realize
that we're all struggling we're all
doing the best that we can we all have
big dreams and goals and desires and
being connected to humanity is learning
to be patient with people to get
number two stay calm how we feel
internally is how we carry ourselves
externally once you can smile when
you're dealing with people that you
don't resonate with difficult people
once you can keep calm that inner
balance is essential keep your head up
a lot of people walk around their whole
life with their head down to the ground
keep your back straight stand your
ground you don't have to become
confrontational with anybody but we all
must tap into our inner power because
the power is within we have to really be
connected to who we are
breathe easy once you can be calm and
not become so reactive a lot of people
that annoy us they want us to fall into
their trap difficult people whether it's
at work wherever it may be they want you
to battle with them whatever you fight
you give energy to therefore resistance
makes stronger once you can become
silent say what you want to say but
become silent within yourself you
develop inner peace and balance and
therefore that difficult person is no
longer difficult there are no difficult
people is how we interpretate what is
difficult it is our interpretation of
what it means to be difficult it's
different for every single person on the
planet take a deep breath and be patient
calm down
go slow don't let other people's
negativity or anger or frustration
affect you step back in your own mind
mentally and just smile you know there's
an old saying if you don't if you can't
say something nice don't talk at all is
my advice sometimes the very best thing
you can do
in dealing with difficult people is just
to be dead silent don't feed the fire by
arguing or getting involved when you're
dealing with a difficult person just
stop the clock like a timeout just smile
and don't say anything and then when you
do say something remember one of the
great communication tools is this is the
person who asks questions has control
the way that you can take control of any
negative situation is not trying to win
but simply by asking questions say you
know what why do you say that or why do
you feel that way or that's an
interesting point of view how did you
come to that point of view or how would
we know that what you say is true I mean
is there any proof or validity instead
of attacking simply ask questions and
it's sort of like the matador backs away
from the bull is you keep backing away
from the bull you cape
the difficult person by simply asking
questions and being genuinely curious
about what he or she is thinking and
feeling and why they are behaving the
way they are sometimes you may find that
they have a good reason sometimes you
may find that they misunderstand
something maybe you will find that they
have a difficult problem in their lives
but in any case be calm be patient be
controlled and ask questions and it will
make you the master of the situation
some people have got a negative blood
group it's just the way some people are
they wear negativity like an old
comfortable coat it just seems to fit
them really well so they're the kind of
people that even if they won the lottery
would say she'll smile look it wasn't
the rollover weak you know in their
mantra for life
never forget every silver lining as a
black cloud but I want us to be careful
of these people because sometimes I
think we need to challenge them because
sometimes I think they're unaware of how
their negativity and their misery can
impact those around them maybe you could
even use them humor to defuse the
situation
you know how long have you been a
motivational speaker then but I think we
need to be careful that although people
might be miserable by Nature let's just
be prepared to challenge that and some
does use humor to defuse the situation
my philosophy on this is really simple
it's the philosophy that life is too
short for dealing with difficult and
toxic people I mean like why why make
life more difficult for yourself life is
already pretty challenging you're
already working really hard on your own
life on your ownself why are you
bringing yourself down with these with
these toxic people there's like there's
no reason for it right so my strategy
here and my solution ultimately is to
get rid of these people out of my life
I want to live a life where the people
that are in my life are supporting me
encouraging the bringing and positivity
they're building they're building
something with me rather than going
against me and so that's kind of the the
ultimate solution Iowa I really want to
get to like the root cause of it here
because a lot of people what they do
what I see them doing is they're so
stuck like in the social matrix they're
so worried about being relied relying
upon various social relationships that
they're not willing to get rid of these
toxic people out of their lives and what
this does is it just it creates this
like spiral of negativity that goes down
and down and down and it brings you with
it and there's no need to live a life
like that in fact what I'm gonna argue
is that you can't really self actualize
you can't really create a powerful and
happy fulfilling life if you're
surrounding yourself with these types of
folks Jim Rohn love Jim Rome has a lot
of great wisdom one of the most wise
things that he said was that you are the
average of the top five associates that
you hang out with what this means is
that if you take and make a list of all
the people in your life and you write a
number down for how many hours per week
you're spending with with each one of
those people and you then rank everybody
according to the number of hours you
spend with them the top five people
that you spend the most time with these
are the people that have the most
influence on you it's a very simple
theory basically whoever you hang out
with is we are going to absorb into
yourself and you kind of become the
average of all that well if this
principle is true then who do you want
to surround yourself with positive
empowering people or negative
disempowering people if you do this
exercise you actually write this out and
you actually tally up the numbers you
might be shocked to discover that you
hang out with some people a lot more
than others you might also be shocked to
discover that some of those people that
you hang out with and spend five or ten
or even twenty hours a week with that
those are super negative super
pessimistic super miserable and
depressive anger prone type of people
and maybe that's why you're not getting
the success you want in your life is
because you're around these type of
people all the time
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what did you think of this
video what was the rule that most
applies to you that you're going to
immediately implement somehow into your
life or your business please let me know
I'd love to hear from you leave it down
in the comments below I also want to
give a quick shout out to Marcus
Campbell Marcus thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and doing the review on it I really
appreciate the support and I'm so glad
that you enjoyed the read today we have
a special book review for you and it's
about your one word by Evan Carmichael
so thank you guys again for watching I
hope you have an amazing day I believe
in you and hope you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word
is much love I'll see you soon
when you think about that person in your
life and usually people have someone
elico I know the difficult person right
the first step is to identify which type
do they fall into there's four main
types difficult people and by the way on
our worst day we all fall into one of
the oh that's right okay so one might
sound familiar so the first one is
Downers
so negative nancies Debbie downers they
complain they come in the room and it's
like the energy just drops out of there
absolutely they complain a lot that kind
of bucket right the second bucket is
better than so these are show-offs
people who name-drop I always hit a
one-up so oh yeah you know like you have
a story you went to Italy and
blah-de-blah
and then someone said oh yeah it'll even
longer is even better all right so they
always like if you have something good
they have something better something big
day of something bigger right
one they name drop things they just they
when people feel on low confidence this
is what they do to make themselves feel
better so they feel like they have to be
better than right okay so the third type
are passes so this happens typically
when people are so low confident that
they don't have a voice so they don't
make decisions right you ask them so
what do you want to do whatever you want
right they can be a little difficult a
little difficult and conversation you
ask them a question they have a one-word
answer right they don't ask you anything
back they're very passive and it's
usually cuz they're afraid they don't
think they're worth it right the fourth
difficult type of person is Downers
passives uppers oh and tanks yeah so
tanks are the ones where they can get
really angry kind of explosive they can
be called bossy which i think is a
banned word days right holy Aussies you
know we're not those to use bossy so
they kind of come in and they want to be
a control freak they're like I want to
take control of the suggestion so they
can be very emotional that's the cue you
want to watch out for so once you
identify the type of person that you're
dealing with the second step and this is
the biggest mistake is you can't try to
fix them right right you have to adjust
to them don't you all right yeah just
enough the problem is is if you try to
tell a tank to calm down
they usually freak out even more right
if you tell a passive to speak up that
makes them even more shy right so if you
try to fix them
that usually makes them even more
uncomfortable sure so the better thing
to do is step three and that's to try to
understand them so if you can shift the
mindset from I don't want to fix them or
change them I want to understand where
they're coming from
I call this finding their value language
so everyone who has a value language
this is something that they in it drives
their actions it's what they hold most
dear so it could be knowledge they want
to know everything or it could be money
that they want huge amounts of financial
success do they all have the same kind
of language I mean does the tank always
have the same kind of language so
typically like better than our
know-it-all okay CLE that goes long but
not always
typically passives usually they want to
be in control their relationships okay
so like to know the people in the room
so figure out and you can do this by
asking really open-ended questions to
figure out what is driving them that
will usually calm them down well give me
an example of a question I would ask a
tank say sure so let's say that you have
a tank an you can see that they're kind
of in control mode when they're walking
around they're trying to control
everything you can say so um tell me
what's been going on for you or instead
of asking like how are you doing or
how's work you can say so are there any
issues that are bothering you or what
personal passion projects are you
working on okay those kind of deeper
questions can usually get them out of
that overbearing mode and into
discussion with you and that leads you
perfectly into the fourth so you've
identified the type where you've said
you're not going to fix them you are
trying to understand them the last one
is to make sure they're not toxic to you
oh good point right so this is all about
you now so making sure you have
boundaries set on time those go downer
can really bring you down it just sucks
the energy out of it okay you know what
I can't bring that down our friend to a
party or if I have a party I can only
talk to them in limited doses right or
they're safe topics so for tanks you
might have someone who when they get
around a certain topic they get really
upset you know that is a no-go topic for
that so don't talk to a tank about
politics right exactly or if it's family
members so I had people with it they're
different right but you have to spend
time around them you're only spending
time with them on their best days so you
know that you know what they're not good
in social situations very much better
one-on-one right we're better off going
to a meal are going to
Coffee so setting up limits either on
time or topics so they don't become
toxic to you and that makes it a lot
more manageable you also have to watch
not getting caught up in there I mean
getting caught up in their drama yeah so
what's interesting is there's something
that called it's called chameleon
ization right so we become like the
person we're with right and so with
difficult people you have to be so
careful that when you're with that
Debbie Downer you don't also get into
that critical gossipy complaining I'm
it's easy to do oh it's so because we
want to be congenial right so we're like
oh if we're angry like them like a tank
or if we're really quiet and a passive
but actually that makes them feel even
worse because you're both getting into
this really bad area if you can just go
into understanding mode they actually
will come out of their shell and they go
into their best self and it passive the
same way if you can do it the same way
because most people try to fix passes
like one of my good friends she's just
very very shy as he will always tell her
speak up oh yeah and that makes her even
more shy so if you ask really specific
directed questions about what you know
what kind of personal passion project
she's working get her talking about
things she's excited about yeah then
she's like and she can relax and she
becomes more active